that means hello Ian garbage human
language hi guys names for something do
not know 99 your life is different now
I'm in another hotel room I'm going
voluntarily outdoors as means of a small
vacation type activity for the rest of
the week but I try to post a video on
Friday but I might not
doesn't mean I'm dead it just means I
don't have cell phone reception or Wi-Fi
and I'm doing it to myself voluntarily I
just have this like lingering annoying
thought that we're all going to die
someday maybe I should disconnect every
now and then as a means to balance out
my mental health I know it's disgusting
don't have high hopes goggle trap but I
thought I've spent so much time in hotel
rooms over the last few years I've
mentally developed a list of Hotel hacks
that might be helpful for you there's a
number that I will determine by the end
of this video of Hotel hacks that might
be useful for you the next time that
you're alone in a hotel room take some
bathroom towels or just use some of the
extra pillows on the bed because they
always put so goddamn many but them
under your duvet covers up feels like
you're laying in bed with another person
that's right as the person doesn't have
a safe so no one can prove if they're
unattractive I like to make my room
service ordering as efficient as
possible therefore I order myself
numerous drinks and then feel like I
might be judged or shamed by the room
service delivery person my food or drink
is getting delivered I run the shower
and close the bathroom door so that the
delivery person thinks that these two
double vodka redbulls are not just for
me prank them so hard if you're feeling
Restless try using a suitcase dance do
some arm exercises or leg exercises or
scare away any villain or a murderer
ghost in a pinch you can use the plastic
bag of cement to fill up the ice bucket
as a stop or just local decals and rub
you acquire on your trip you can just
take the hairdryer you can use the
ironing board as a TV tray if your
that's boozy you can use the telephone
cord to help paint your toenails I know
you're thinking that it's disgusting but
you're also thinking that it's genius
and you're torn I know you can take that
informative hotel binder and remove all
the informative hotel papers and now you
have a binder for back to school for
free ish use on HBO Game of Thrones
promotional dances masturbation material
it's free and you don't have to panic
about clearing your web browser after
then well there you go guys there are
some of my hopefully helpful hotel hacks
for you and your future hotel endeavors
let me know which one is your favorite
and if any of you guys out there have
any other hacks to add to the mix if you
liked this video give it a thumbs up and
don't forget to click Subscribe it does
notification bail to because I make
videos Monday Wednesday and Friday
sometimes I don't know
[Music]